[Musique]
je suis né et j'habite sur une très
belle île une île magnifique la nouvelle
calédonie et les habitants qui habitent
se sent très concerné par
l'environnement car pour eux
l'environnement c'est vital
c'est le centre de leur vie n'est ce pas
pas un papier par terre
pas de vidange dans les rivières une
gestion intelligente de l'énergie
mais le plus préoccupant dans tout ça
c'est que la nouvelle calédonie est l'un
des pays qui rejette le plus de gaz à
effet de serre pourquoi et bien tout
simplement parce qu'ils à 3 énorme usine
métallurgique qui concentre toute une
quantité astronomique de charbon
je m'appelle margie à junior je suis une
fille d'ouvéa c'est une petite île au
nord de la nouvelle calédonie j'ai été
faire mes études au québec pendant
quatre ans en chimie analytique et j'ai
eu l'opportunité d'intégrer un groupe de
chercheurs dans le projet était porté et
se porte actuellement sur le charme
envers ses mentors rémy larouche qui m'a
vraiment ouvert les yeux sur les défis
que doit relever mon pays je me souviens
encore de lui en 2013 qui me disait en
tabarouette jj tomber il va tu vraiment
installer une nouvelle centrale à
charbon là à temps mais tu sais tu que
ton pays va beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
pollué
dis moi je t'ai comme non j'avais pas ok
j'ai quelque chose à te proposer tu veux
tu faire une belle job pour tous et mais
surtout pourtant pays l'eau je te
propose de travailler avec vous et sur
le charbon vert ok
mais en réalité j'ai pris conscience que
la situation était grave qu'elle était
même très grave pour qu'un québécois
s'intéressent à ma petite île du bout du
monde et c'est clair que la situation
est grave en nouvelle calédonie ok
certes les énergies renouvelables sont
utilisés l'énergie hydraulique comme le
barrage se gâter où les éoliennes qui
sont installés dont le sud et le nord de
la nouvelle calédonie ou encore
l'énergie solaire par exemple ici à
l'île des pins
mais cette production d'énergie reste
marginal par rapport à celles provenant
du charbon alors c'est clair que en
nouvelle calédonie 80 % de l'électricité
produite provient de la combustion du
charbon
et c'est là qu'entre en jeu mon charbon
vert mais avant d'aller plus loin
j'aimerais vous rappeler ce qu'est un
charbon allez petit cours de bio de 4e
alors le charbon que vous connaissiez
tous du charbon minéral c'est
l'accumulation de débris végétaux et
animaux qui vend c'est d'y monter et
carbonisé à la suite de différentes
phases de température et de pression et
ce durant plusieurs millions d'années
le charbon qu'on appelle vers man
charmant et aussi issus des végétaux
sauf qu'il est fabriqué en quelques
heures on peut aussi lui fabriqué à
partir de la boue des stations
d'épuration ou des restes alimentaires
bref pour faire simple on dit qu'on
fabrique le charbon vert avec de la
biomasse
mais dans les deux cas le charbon
minéral et le charme envers proviennent
de la photosynthèse la photosynthèse
vous vous souvenez or c'est très simple
c'est une plante qui va capter du co2 et
grâce à l'énergie solaire vont fabriquer
de la matière barre des feuilles des
tiges de bois et là vous allez me dire
ok orgie le charbon vert et le charbon
minéral sont tous les deux fabriqués à
partir des végétaux où se situe la
différence
pourquoi un des deux charbon et vert et
pas l'autre
et bien c'est très simple dans le tas du
charbon minéral le co2 a été capté il y
à des millions d'années lorsqu'on brûle
ce charbon le co2 relargués dans
l'atmosphère est un co2 préhistorique
qui vient bousculer rattrapant ce fer le
charbon vers le co2 a été capté il y a
peu de temps donc quelques heures avec
de l'herbe ou quelques mois avec les
branches d'arbre ou au maximum des
années avec des arbres en entier on peut
dire que ces plantes vient à peine de
mourir le co2 rejeté lors de la
combustion du charbon vert c'était co2
jeunes le bilan carbone est donc neutre
ça c'est la première grosse différence
la deuxième d'une grosse différence
c'est que lorsqu'on brûle du charbon
minéral
ils rejettent du soufre le charbon vers
nom de charbon minéral
oui et le soufre ça a quoi comme
conséquence les plus fluides et les
maladies respiratoires
l'idée est donc de fabriquer du charbon
vert à partir de la biomasse disponible
en nouvelle calédonie mais comme on fait
concrètement comment se fabrique le
charbon vert et bien c'est assez simple
dans le principe où il faut d'abord
déshydraté la matière végétale
ensuite la tour y fier comme 'pourris'
fier du café puis la compacte et est ce
que mon charbon est un charbon de bonne
qualité je dirais même qu'il est
excellent le travail que j'ai réalisé
avec rémy larouche au québec ont
démontré que la capacité calorifique du
charbon est égal à 95% par rapport à
celle du meilleur charbon minéral en
effet nous l'avons comparé à un charmant
haut de gamme un charbon de laboratoire
donc je peux dire que man charbon étain
est meilleur que la plupart des charbons
minéraux en nouvelle calédonie une étude
technico-économique de la ressources en
biomasse a été menée ce qui a permis
d'identifier un potentiel de biomasse co
établie annuellement donc 4500 tonnes de
déchets organiques hors eaux usées
valorisables par méthanisation
trente mille tonnes de déchets verre et
de bois 4000 tonnes de boues de station
d'épuration de 1300 tonnes de produits
connexes de scierie brève tout plein
chiffres pour dire qu'il y a trente deux
mille trois cents tonnes de biomasse
disponible en nouvelle calédonie par an
et on pourrait produire huit mille
tonnes de charbon vert économiquement le
projet est ultra un viable nous avons un
coût de production de 100 $ pour une
tonne de charbon vert sachant que mon
charbon vert est un charbon de haute
qualité sur le marché il se vend à 650
dollars la tonne nous avons un profit de
550 $ et on gagne jackpot si en produits
8000 tonnes de charbon vert nous avons 5
millions de dollars en gros 500 millions
de francs
la nouvelle calédonie pourrait être un
exemple pour ses pays voisins qui sont
confrontés aux mêmes enjeux
c'est pour ça que le projet du charbon
vert est carrément primordial pour le
pays je suis conscient que produire huit
mille tonnes de charbon vert c'est pas
grand chose comparé aux 100000 tonnes de
charbon minéral importé est utilisé par
l' usine de nouméa
soyons optimistes non ouais on peut très
facilement compléter la fabrication du
charbon vert en important les déchets
verts de nos pays voisins comme la
nouvelle-zélande l'australie le vanuatu
et cette idée n'est pas folle d'autres
pays le font déjà
exemple la norvège qui depuis cinq ans
importe les déchets verts de ses pays
voisins pour en fabriquer de
l'électricité
pourquoi on ne ferait pas ici en
nouvelle calédonie c'est possible alors
l'horizon s'éclaircit sur meu sur la
nouvelle calédonie imaginez un peu nous
avons un profit de 5 millions de dollars
pour 8000 tonnes 8000 tonnes de charbon
vert imaginé le profit qu'on ferait si
en produits nous mêmes cent mille tonnes
de charbon vert si on produit nous mêmes
notre charbon un charbon écolo on
arrêtera de contribuer au changement
climatique
on aura une meilleure qualité d'air
moins de maladies respiratoires moins de
pluies acides
la nouvelle calédonie sera indépendante
énergétiquement
on créera une économie circulaire en
créera des emplois et en créera des
richesses en tout cas moi je dis ça je
dis rien à bientôt
[Applaudissements]